Japan was prior to an American Fleet
turning up a famously closed country one
in which trade with the outside world
was severely limited and illegally
setting foot in the country was met with
the death penalty yet despite this
hostility to All Things foreign the
Dutch was still permitted to trade there
this raises the obvious question why why
were all foreign Traders banned except
for the Dutch Japan was first visited by
Europeans in the mid-16th century when
some Portuguese traders turned up from
China it was fortunate for them because
shortly after this Japan and China
weren't trading anymore due to a falling
out and so the Portuguese realized that
they could make a lot of money as
intermediaries they also realized that
this brand new land was suffering from a
distinct lack of Jesus despite it having
a single Emperor Japan was decentralized
at this point with numerous Regional
Lords trying to out-compete their
neighbors for power and for them
Christianity or at least good relations
with Christians brought one major
advantage guns the Portuguese sold
Firearms to the Japanese and they were
Keen to make sure that they went to the
Christians first and thus to other Noble
Japanese houses is Christianity was the
threat to Japanese culture tradition and
their power and so in the early 17th
century after a Civil War ended in the
establishment of the Tokugawa shogunate
the Shoguns decided that Christianity
needed to be dealt with the first way
that they did this was to restrict trade
with Christians to Nagasaki thus making
it easier to keep an eye on them however
the Portuguese continued to smuggle
missionaries into Japan and after a
Christian Rebellion the government
outlawed the religion entirely during
this Rebellion the Dutch had provided
guns and support to the central
government and earn their gratitude now
you may think that it was weird for the
Christian Dutch to Aid a heathen
government against Christians but one
those were Catholics and thus to the
Protestant Dutch they were the wrong
Christians and two money after the
Rebellion the shogunate thanked the
Dutch East India Company for its support
and so gave them exclusive rights to
trade via Nagasaki this was done on
three conditions the first was that the
Dutch had to support and comply with
government rules without question the
second was that they agreed to never try
to convert the Japanese to Christianity
and the third was that the Dutch had to
send a delegation to Edo every year this
was to renew their pledge and also give
the government an update on what was
going on in places like Korea and China
just in case it was something that they
needed to know other nations tried to
open up trade but the Japanese either
didn't know them and so had to rely on
what the Dutch had to say about them or
in the case of the English they knew of
their allies with the Portuguese and so
quickly told them to go elsewhere now
whilst the Dutch were given a monopoly
on trade that doesn't mean that the two
liked each other the Japanese were happy
to trade with the Dutch East India
Company but they wanted nothing to do
with the Dutch Republic and refused any
diplomatic relations with them and when
the Dutch East India Company was
replaced by the Dutch East Indies Colony
the Japanese were still Keen to limit
the relationship to just trade much to
their own detriment since in 1853 the
Dutch at Nagasaki warned the shogunate
of an American Armada which was coming
to force Japan to open trade the Shogun
believed that this was a lie made up to
sell military equipment to Japan that it
didn't need and so this warning was
promptly ignored until Matthew Perry
turned up that was an ended Japanese
isolation and forced the Edo government
to trade with everyone thereafter
I hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patreon supporters
James bizzinet Kelly moneymaker Sky
Chappelle call show wolf katritska
Adam's daughter Jerry lambdin Alex
Schwinn Jordan Longley Marcus arsner rod
D Martin why in hockey Spencer Lightfoot
Captain Psy dog Marvin Castle boogly
Wiggly kimun Yoon Winston K with Aaron
the white the mcwhopper Miss is it
Maggie paxkowski Gustav Swan Anthony
Beckett Coppertone shewenin spinning
three plates Charles the first and words
about books podcast